Conny wrote in different countries are
known for different things this is not a
which country is better thing but what
does your birth country of Argentina get
rights compared to other countries well
nobody can do corruption like Argentina
Argentina really does all sorts of
political corruption corruption and
institutional corruption really really
well I would say asado or what is known
as you know the the barbecuing and
grilling of various meats is absolutely
top-notch in Argentina the pasta and the
pizza I mean a lot of the food is is
really great in Argentine empanadas or
fantastic
pastries are excellent because of the
French influence heavy on the butter not
for vegans for sure sarcasm sarcasm is
absolutely top-notch in Argentina if
you've met Argentinians and I've spoken
to them in mostly any setting you would
know sarcasm is a really really big
thing down there interestingly software
development is quite good in Argentina
yeah there's a lot of software
development companies that are based in
Argentina that work with companies in
the US and Europe added at a lower cost
because of the lower cost of living
there so that I think is a thing
Argentina gets right psychotherapy the
capital city in Argentina of Buenos
Aires at one point had the highest
concentration of psychotherapists per
capita up there with I believe New York
City so that is that's something I think
we could say Argentina gets right those
are a few things I not all of these are
good things that's pretty exciting I
don't know you want me to add to all
this well do those things sound like it
would be an interesting place to visit
or when you hear that Argentina really
knows how to do corruption does that
make you think maybe it's not the place
for me I mean as a traveler maybe I'll
be less susceptible to be an item of
corruption yeah there's so much natural
beauty I hear and there and also Buenos
Aires sounds like a phenomenal city to
me yeah it is and that's not actually
it's good that Pat is mentioning that if
you're looking for a variety of
beautiful landscapes yes everything from
arid higher elevation elevation desert
like pre tropical all the way down to
effectively Antarctic weather you can
get it all glaciers mountains the entire
thing I think that that's that's one of
the pluses of Argentina maybe work for
their tourism industry sure there's
always a need for english-speaking
people to work in the in the tourism
industry so anyway I hope that these
aren't seen as all bad things because
there's really a lot of great stuff in
Argentina